what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we're back into our how to kill
Super Heroes series um I might just do
this for like the next little while I'll
probably go to Ryan like easy got the
rights to scripts and just be like hey
just give me just start giving me
scripts on superheroes that we haven't
killed yet and like we'll just kill them
you know for a little while I think
that'd be kind of cool but anyway like
Panthers coming out this weekend so of
course we have to celebrate by killing
Black Panther because we've killed like
so many other superheroes so far so it
makes sense that we have to celebrate
this but as we always do in these videos
on on how to kill superheroes we got to
have to outline you know what these
characters are capable of what they can
do and why it is that it would be pretty
hard to take him out or maybe very easy
to take him out it really kind of
depends so the first thing we really
need to do here is take an inventory of
the powers the Black Panther has so
first things first because he has
attained the rank of chief of the
Panther clan Black Panther is permitted
to partake in the heart shaped curve
which is a plant native to Wakanda that
due to its exposure to the vibranium
meteorite has mutated to give those that
consume it enhanced abilities like speed
strength endurance agility healing and
senses so at a baseline level although
Black Panther doesn't actually have
super powers he is ahead of the curve
due to these enhanced physical
attributes and I would argue as
controversial this might be I would
argue he's probably on the same level as
Captain America and it really kind of
depends on what rider we're talking
about if we're talking about like Rick
Remender Captain America then probably
on the same level I mean I imagine that
I think that are they fought during that
story maybe black panther I'm sorry
Captain America one but like Reginald
Hudlin run or like Chris or a priest
like Black Panthers one so it depends on
who's writing this story but the fact
remains if Khan had gone back and forth
in terms of you know who's the most
capable regarding their their various
head-to-head combats and different
things like that now in addition to
these physical attributes T'Challa also
possesses a genius-level intellect and
is among the smartest characters and
Marvel Comics with his intelligence
rivaling people like Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner now not only does this
intelligence allow to chala to be an
expert physicist in engineer but also
makes him an expert in battle tactics
furthermore T'Challa is a master of
hand-to-hand combat which is not
surprising considering that he has been
training for combat since the day he was
born maybe other day he was born does he
get first like walk but he is an expert
in a wide variety of martial arts styles
and his master nearly every weapon known
to man
although
is especially fond of bladed weapons
like daggers and Spears all that needs
to be said about Black Panthers prowess
as a fighter is that he's defeated
people like Captain America and
daredevil and Iron Fist and Deadpool
he's fought and defeated a wide array of
different people who were out there now
despite all these attributes however
what's really going to be the main
obstacle in killing Black Panther is the
vibranium mesh suit that he wears
now I released a video earlier this week
we're really kind of a last week or
something like that where we basically
went over all the things that Black
Panther suit can do so if you watch that
video this is all going to be kind of a
I guess a run over of the stuff that
we've already talked about but for those
of you guys who is who have not seen
that video black panther suit is
constructed of a mesh made of vibranium
one of the hardest strongest and most
durable metals in the Marvel Universe
which also has the unique property of
absorbing all the kinetic energy of
anything that comes into contact with so
if a bullet or any other projectile hits
Black Panther suit instead of just
ricocheting off it would simply lose all
of its momentum and drop to the ground
now black panther suit also features
boots that can dampen energy fields and
allow him to convert achill surfaces and
even walk across water as well as create
hard light shielding cloak itself and
has teleportation technology now in
terms of offensive weapons the black
panther suit contains claws made of a
special type of vibranium that we call
an T metal and is basically capable of
breaking down metal at the molecular
level effectively turning it into a
liquid source now Black Panther also has
energy daggers which are vibranium
blades that use energy to slice through
enemies and can even be used in close
combat or as projectiles so clearly
taking down Black Panther is not an easy
task but can it be done well I think the
answer is a definitive yes I mean after
all
Black Panther at its core is still just
a human being I'm sure he has like
enhanced strength and durability he has
a highly advanced suit of armor and he's
a really really good fighter but at the
end of the day he's not a celestial he's
not like a God he's just a guy with some
enhanced abilities and that basically
means he can be destroyed if it bleeds
we can kill it whoever knows where that
phrase is from post a comment tell me
what that's from of all the people who
get it right I'll pick one of you guys
and one of you will get a Rob core ring
we simply have to figure out how and I
think this is a good way to basically
rule out what we don't want to do but we
have to figure out how it is that we're
gonna confront Black Panther and I think
one of the things that we don't want to
do the first thing we don't want to do
is confront Black Panther in what Conda
now the reason for this is simple
T'Challa
is the king of Wakanda and as such he
has an entire army at the ready to do
his bidding so that's something that
we're going to want to avoid since we
simply don't want to like complicate the
matter by taking out Black Panther and
then forcing ourselves to have to take
out an entire army of well-trained
soldiers armed to the teeth with the
most advanced technological weaponry in
the world at the same time we also want
to avoid getting in close quarters
hand-to-hand combat with Black Panther
for the reasons we discussed earlier and
then of course you have the vibranium
suit absorbing all the blows that he
takes complicating things even further
so this doesn't really seem like the
best option for us to use with that in
mind the question becomes what can we do
well we've pretty much conceded the fact
that we are going to have to attack
Black Panther with a ranged weapon
either a bullet or grenade or something
along those lines but I think that we
should steer clear of explosives because
even though they are capable of
releasing a great deal of energy the
vibranium in Black Panthers suit is
probably going to be able to absorb it I
mean sure
maybe it's possible to create a big
enough explosion that the amount of
ibrehem within a suit can't absorb it
all but we're talking about using a
massive amount of energy and at the end
of the day I'm not okay with like carpet
bombing or nuking Wakanda just to
destroy Black Panther so yeah we're not
gonna nuke we're not gonna nuke Wakanda
but as we stated earlier vibranium is
one of the hardest and most durable
metals in the Marvel Universe but it's
neither as hard nor as durable as
another well-known metal adamantium now
adamantium is a metal that coats
Wolverine's skeleton and is probably one
of the strongest metals in the Marvel
Universe probably the second strongest
metal in the Marvel Universe with the
possible exception of Uri metal which is
what Thor's hammer is made of now the
adamantium versus vibranium debate is
one that comic book fans have gone back
and forth on for years but there's a lot
of misinformation out there about the
relative strengths of the two metals
much of which stems from Captain
America's shield so there have been a
few instances in comics where we've seen
Wolverines adamantium claws
unsuccessfully pierce Captain America's
shield now this is often been cited as
proof that adamantium cannot cut through
vibranium but this over
the fact that Captain America's shield
in the comics is not made of pure
vibranium but is a type of alloy of
vibranium iron and adamantium also known
as proto atta mantium now this is the
substance that adamantium doesn't seem
to be able to cut through not pure
vibranium and so this black panther suit
contains a mesh weave of pure vibranium
I think it's safe to assume that
adamantium can cut through it something
else I also want to point out here now
that I think about it Thor's hammer is
not the strongest metal not the
strongest material in the universe the
strongest material the strongest metal
in in the Marvel Universe is infact
Captain America shield because it's made
of pure freedom that's not true because
of the fact that it is a proto
adamantium the idea of Captain America
getting like a shield that's incredibly
durable was that what we ended up having
was a scientist of sorts who is a
metallurgist who is brought in by the
federal government to make Captain
America a new shield what he did he was
given a sample of vibranium by Captain
America which was given to Captain
America by Wakanda for helping to defeat
the forces of Hydra and ultimately where
the scientists had essentially just kind
of like fallen asleep at the wheel he
woke up to like a new metallic compound
which was basically what Captain
America's shield was made out of now the
scientists tried to duplicate this
material and stumbled across adamantium
so that's how that whole thing kind of
comes into existence so while we might
be able to use an adamantium bullet for
this task adamantium is at its most
effective when it bares a sharpened edge
like Wolverines claws so what I propose
is that since we still need to attack
Black Panther from a distance but we
want the cutting power of a sharp edge
something like an adamantium harpoon who
would probably do the trick of piercing
black panther suit as well as his vital
organs what you know would kill him
because I mean you know it's he's a guy
but yeah it's kind of weird because when
I sat down and thought about this the
vibranium sued the vibranium mesh suit
is like the most difficult thing that's
the hardest thing about it if it wasn't
for that we could just shoot him like we
could just say okay like we're just
gonna snipe him from a rooftop you know
we could just run him through with a
knife there's any number of things that
we could do the problem is that the it's
not like Batman's suit right like that
has a cloaking Cal but like his lower
jaw is exposed so if you knew who Batman
was you if you saw him there and he just
sniped if he had a you know accurate
enough sniper you could just shoot him
in the lower jaw and blow off the bottom
of his head but with regards to black
panther doesn't work that way his whole
body is covered from head to toe even
his eyes have kind of like a covering on
them that keeps every aspect of his
physical body protected there's no weak
point when it comes to like
a vibranium mesh weave that he wears so
I mean it's if this is like the only
thing I can think of you know just
shooting him with like a adamantium
harpoon and that'd be kind of funny that
sounds like a Deadpool story you know
worse like it's like it's like Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe for the third
time because he's already done it twice
and like Deadpool shows up with like a
giant adamantium harpoon you know like
like Clint Eastwood out of like you know
dead out of the Deadpool oh my god we
just made a pun okay so there's a deer a
Dirty Harry movie called the Deadpool
and it's hilarious I think it's called
Deadpool not the Deadpool well the whole
funny thing about this is at the end of
the movie he shoots it oh my god he
shoots a guy with a harpoon I can't
believe we just did that I can't believe
we just made that connection oh man I am
I am hilarious I am amazing sometimes
anyway uh yeah so that's that's the only
way I could really see us see I cannot
believe we did that I had no I didn't
even think about that if you guys ever
saw that Dirty Harry movie by the way if
you never saw the Deadpool you guys
gotta go see you gotta go check it out
it's awesome later bye guys if you are
new here two comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and uh yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you